my objective
is to make it financially unsustainable
for them to continue to kill black
people unjustly
[Music]
the film civil deals
with many meanings obviously
i'm a civil trial lawyer a civil rights
lawyer not a criminal
justice lawyer i don't have any power to
arrest a person and to put them in jail
and hold them criminally accountable and
i think nadia hogan
did a very important job showing the
distinction i was home
in may in lockdown just like the rest of
america
and
you know my last home becoming came out
early in may and three weeks later
george floyd was murdered you know as a
black filmmaker i'm just sitting home
thinking
i have to be doing something i have to
be out there i have to be telling a
story this is what i do
and i was really scratching my head just
trying to figure out where do i get in
where's my jump off how do i begin to
tell the story of this historical moment
that's happening shortly after that
the phone rings and it's kenya barris
and he tells me i'm working on this
project with ben crump and we're looking
for a documentary filmmaker to
basically
jump in with him right now it's all
going down
and we want to make this film and he's
like are you interested and it was just
like
everything that i had put out there and
had hoped for had just came to me i met
them very quickly on a zoom
and i knew that that was that was the
next thing that i had to do i do want to
pay the utmost respect to kenya barris
and roger ross williams our incredible
producers roger has such gravitas when
it comes to the documentary film space
and then to kenya barris you know this
young man who's trying to project the
black experience of america onto the
screen
all i did was pack my camera bag and get
on the road i had no idea what i was
getting myself into when i joined
attorney crump what i immediately
saw was just
this person who had
an incredible warmth to him a sense of
humor
sort of this personality that i think
was really unexpected that we often
don't think of when we think of civil
rights lawyers so as a filmmaker that
really enjoys character studies i knew
that that would really draw an audience
into him and his story and his fight and
so that was a really important part to
me to make sure that that really shines
amongst all the other things that he was
doing but to stay connected to him as as
a very very unique individual and
watching this documentary
it is a salute to
the genius of nadia hogan i had things
revealed to me that i was not even aware
of i try to compartmentalize
all of this and not give way to emotions
but what she captured a lot of
was
after i would talk to family members and
different people i would find myself
rubbing my head rubbing my temples
and so forth and i never was aware that
i did that so much it was almost like a
physical
manifestation
of the mental anguish i was dealing with
and dealing with this uh tragic loss of
life you know we have a scene in the
film we call banking while black and
there's this young mother shira brown
who goes to cash 90 check and gets
accused of committing fraud and the
police get called on her and it's so sad
and that experience left her unable to
buy milk for her babies when i was
filming a scene like that i
tears were just falling into my
viewfinder you know we have stories of
people being murdered and things like
that in the film that are also deeply
sad
but that story reminded me of my own
mother and experiences that i've had in
my life i just think that having that
very personal connection to the people
in the film and the experiences allowed
me to tell the story in a way that i
hope is very nuanced and deeply
resonates with our audiences because
we know that that's something that not
everyone will experience but everyone
needs to know
is something that happens i'm often
asked
being how do you deal with the mental
strain the mental anguish of dealing
with such
heartache such tragedy such as death on
a constant basis
and i i'm a student of history so
i look back at what my personal hero
thurgood marshall said about dealing
with constant injustices he said you
have to stay focused on the mission
because if you're not focused on the
mission if you become emotional and you
can't be strong to stay focused then you
can't prevent future
is from happening and so when these
families who have experienced
the worst loss imaginable what you are
trying to do is be strong for them too
in that moment when they need somebody
to try to help them make sense of
something that makes no sense whatsoever
and so i just try to focus on the
mission
i was very fortunate to have
one of the most talented edit teams i
think working in documentary filmmaking
we had lindsey utts anasity and nathan
pumwar i had some deep conversations
with them about the experience that i
had with ben and what was important for
me to highlight in terms of
his personality and really who he was so
when we went in to
craft our story some of the first things
we did was pull those moments knowing
that this is a very heavy film it's very
emotional
and what would help bring levity to some
of these deeply tragic stories was ben
we tried a lot of things you know it's
all like one big experiment that one day
just works you know and
you just hope it works within your edit
schedule
i'm in the public's eye so much but
that's in my professional life on a very
specific mission it's another thing
entirely for me to be the subject
of the camera lens not just my work but
my personal life
uh my family life and so
it was a big decision but in talking
with kenya bearish our executive
producer and then getting to meet nadia
hogan this uh just young
uh
genius
behind the camera they
made me feel a little more trusting to
put my life on center stage
with all of that said
it still was uh
concerning because a lot of what i do is
a safety issue and i'm okay
with it being me but to have my family
and the people you love most now become
known and then possibly have a lot of
the insults or anything was very
concerning to me but nadia promised me
that she would be very careful so i did
it because i understood the mission and
the mission is we have to speak truth to
power not only in the court of law but
more importantly in the court of public
opinion
ben always is talking about speaking
truth to power and i think for me as a
documentary filmmaker you know i'm an
observational documentary filmmaker and
i think that what i hope we're able to
do with this film is without having to
add anything extra to just what was
happening that people can really see
these stories and and the powers that be
are able to understand more what's
happening i mean what we try to do is
take these moments that ben has
especially with families that he's
interacting with
and show what we don't see in the news
and show the ripple effects of these
these stories that just feel like they
cycle in so quickly we almost aren't
even able to keep up with them i know
that we have this incredible global
audience
on netflix to share this film with and
that's something that i'm really
grateful for the movement that happened
in 2020 and 2021 was a global movement
we show in the film that there were
people that took to the streets in south
korea and austria and places that
you may not even expect but it was that
global mobilization that really put the
pressure on in america to say you need
to look at this you see you need to see
what's happening and so we pay an homage
to that global
group of people who like stood up for us
you know and like connected with our
experiences i'm excited for people to
see that and see themselves in this film
globally and just to have a deeper
understanding of black life in america
and how
deeply woven racism is in every corner
of our lives looking at what attorney
ben crump does and like he says in the
film get into the arena and do something
we can all do something you know i
really encourage people to to take that
as a call to action and be like cool i
could do something too it is my hope
that people
think about
the netflix documentary silver for
exactly what the word denotes
not more than ever is that we champion
tolerance that we champion
humanity that we
champion
civility
and being civil versus
resorting to violence we have to show
our children
that
there
is
humanity in all of us and we should show
respect to that humanity
[Music]
[Music]